an explosion in ticket sales chris rock
is more popular than ever will he talk
about the slap apocalypse at his next
stand up show stick around for
everything we know
will smith's unforgettable slap of chris
rock during the live broadcast of the
94th academy awards ceremony is going
down as one of the most memorable
moments in live television broadcast
history the uncomfortable altercation
came in response to rock's joke about
jada pinkett smith's short hairstyle
which is a result of her struggles with
alopecia the whole night turned even
more bizarre when smith won the award
for best actor some 30 minutes later and
was allowed to return to the stage to
make a tear-filled speech about being a
vessel for love and pointedly offered
apologies to the academy and the show's
audience but not to rock himself the
slap left social media ablaze and has
inspired think pieces on the nature of
rock's joke smith's response and the
academy's inability to handle an
unprecedented altercation during the
show as well as plenty of memes from
social media users along the way
smith offered up a personal apology to
rock via instagram the day after the
ceremony similarly jada pinkett smith
posted a graphic on instagram calling
for healing according to the hollywood
reporter live events ticket company
stubhub said that their ticket sales for
rock's current tour have exponentially
increased in popularity in the days
since the academy awards jumping to
about 250 on average for each ticket and
selling more tickets this week than the
rest of march combined a stubhub
spokesperson told thr that daily ticket
sales for rocks shows are currently 25
times higher than the rest of the month
clearly people are anxious to see
whether the comedian will work being
slapped by will smith into his upcoming
sets what a lovely audience i want to
thank you all for showing up drive home
safely tip your waitresses i gots to go
on stage he appeared shocked at smith's
bad reaction to his gi jane joke before
composing himself and moving on with
presenting the award for best
documentary feature rock reportedly made
a backstage joke about being slapped by
muhammad ali to oscar's crew members in
reference to smith's role as the
legendary boxer in 2001's ali but has
otherwise remained quiet rock's tour
dubbed the ego death world tour is
currently slated to run through november
18th according to the comedian's website
coincidentally the tour is scheduled to
end with two shows at the dolby theater
in los angeles where the academy awards
took place as ticket sales continued to
skyrocket for rock's upcoming eco-death
world tour much of the focus has shifted
toward his now sold out shows in boston
as the comic arrived in boston before
his first show he was asked by the
paparazzi if he had time to answer any
questions he didn't respond to reporters
instead saving it for his show somewhat
according to published reports rock
started his act with the quip how was
your weekend before getting slightly
more serious
i'm still kind of processing what
happened at some point i'll talk about
that and it will be serious and funny
but right now i'm going to tell some
jokes when rock announced the ego death
world tour his first cross-country tour
in five years he said it would feature
new introspective material that was very
personal and very funny now more than
ever he has the chance to capitalize on
a timely unprecedented scenario that
broke the internet
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrity moments are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]